What supplements would you recommend to woman in their 40s low energy? I have ordered many supplements, but I'm guessing
Which I take them with food if I don't take them with food. Okay, even when I take them with food, I feel nauseous
So I'd take them with many different times also. Oh, well. Thank you very much
Okay, so what supplements should you take woman over their 40s low energy?
really
So in general, so in general what supplements should a person take when they get to be over 40 you really
What a supplement is is you're supplementing your diet your your first time to look at making sure you're getting your nutrients through your food is the best way to go
Oh, well, I can't get all my nutrients through my food. I'm busy. I'm not eating as well as I know I should be eating
Well, then taking a multiple
Vitamin would be a good thing to take in most people's minds and and in most for most for a lot of people
That would be just fine. The problem is most multiple vitamins are synthetic so
They can actually do more harm than good. So I like whole food things as much as possible. So
In general, taking like our greens first product would probably be a better whole food
supplement as far as getting your nutrients cold, but I have to take a couple steps back to answer this question really want to
Figure out what's going on. So if I have low energy, you know, you always have to get back to asking that one simple little question
Why why why why why why do I have low energy? It's it because I have low thyroid do I have low energy because
I have you know, low adrenal glands do I have low energy because my pituitary gland do I have low energy because I have
food sensitivity to have low energy because I am an autoimmune issue that I'm not even addressing do I have low energy because I am
toxicity issues sluggish gallbladder can cause low energy. I mean the list is literally endless
So getting some diagnostic workup to me is always best. Otherwise, you're just throwing darts at the law. So
Figure out the reason why
And then you you start treating that that diagnosis
Or a subset of diagnoses to try to clear out that person to see what's best for them
So in general if a person says what's a good multivitamin to take I'm really healthy
But I want to stay healthy that I would say like greens
Whole food greens product
We have a private labeled
prenatal vitamin
But I regret private labeling as a prenatal because it's a whole food
It's the only whole food prenatal vitamin I think on the market
So it's a great
multivitamin, but it's a whole food
Multivitamin not just for women carried baby
So if you're if you're like I can't take greens things. We'll actually have greens in capsules
also
But if you want a vitamin that's a whole food vitamin that would be our prenatal complete that's not a private label product
But as far as giving symptoms like a have low energy of try to figure out so we really need to
We need to dig into this a little bit
So whoever asks this question really schedule a case review with me
um, and then we can dig into why you
Have these issues because when you say what I take all my vitamins even with food I feel nauseous
Um, there's something going on. Yeah, it could very well be as simple as just an HCl deficiency and take it to HCl
um
Which your food might be the issue
Um, but it could be even it could be much something much more complex
You could actually have antibodies to collagen you could have antibodies to
What they what they make even natural supplement capsules out of
And people can feel worse when they take supplements because they have antibodies to that
gelatin stuff so
Um, you got to kind of dig into this to figure this out
Um, sometimes our answers aren't as easy as that